looks fantastic thank you look
absolutely amazing and I love I love the
shirt it's fantastic my stylist Stacy
Caltrain designed this gave it to me as
a surprise it's a sprinters body and the
head of a cockatiel it's what does it
does it have significance I mean it's
the the inspiration for the character
originally was a cockatiel the smart
bird I created a surround the idea of a
smart bird so when I walk I do this
thing well that's right daddy need a lot
of sunflower seeds and stuff now that I
know where it came from complex how I
work exactly on everything of lampshades
but yeah I have once had dinner with
Anthony Hopkins I invited him over for
dinner and he accepted yeah and I was
trying to read a big book when he got
there home I just give me a tome and he
came over and we had dinner together and
I told him that that's how I approached
Ace Ventura and it was a smart bird and
he went I do that I do that Hannibal
Lecter was a cross between a crocodile
and a spider a tarantula spider with
infinite patience infinite time to just
wait the perfect moment I was eating
dinner with him and frankly it got a
little creepy yeah I did it started
getting creepy I started going more
roast beef man there's plenty in the
kitchen no human on me yeah yeah we just
showed a clip from kidding this is the
second season if we're bragging
I get to show an appropriate response
yeah rub that my face why don't you hey
actually I was very proud to be in the
you were in this opening episode ever
touch me I was in sorry there's a giant
sign backstage Joe touch code now you
know I can't breathe but yeah I was on
the first episode and you set such an
impossibly high bar we have a clip not a
clip I think we have a still of me in
the first episode of Aaron
look at you you come on just like you
just suck in the focus all the focus is
going right over there you know but you
just like set this bar so high from then
on the cast was just eating scraps from
your table yeah I talked to Joaquin
Phoenix about your part on the thing he
said that you your depiction of a talk
show host made him want to shoot you in
the eye
[Laughter]
Wow it was that good yeah thank you good
that is a very very